American Horror Story has been able to bring
back many of its cast members again and again
in new roles every season, without boring
viewers.
Why?
Because the show's makeup and personality
transformations have made the actors virtually
unrecognizable from one year to the next.
Here are the best American Horror Story on-screen
transformations...so far.
Ethel Darling
Kathy Bates has had many memorable roles on
American Horror Story over the years.
But her character from Freak Show is perhaps
her most iconic yet.
In the fourth season, Bates played Ethel Darling,
a world-weary bearded lady with such a no-nonsense
attitude that audiences could sometimes even
forget the facial hair was even there.
Papa Legba
When you're gatekeeper to the spirit world,
you'd better look the part.
In American Horror Story: Coven, Lance Reddick
did just that as the voodoo-inspired Papa
Legba and was completely convincing as the
otherworldly character.
"Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha"
Aileen Wuornos
Lily Rabe had big shoes to fill when it came
to playing real-life serial killer Aileen
Wuornos.
After all, Charlize Theron won an Oscar for
her portrayal in 2003's Monster.
Rabe offered a sauntering performance for
American Horror Story: Hotel, but her methodical
mannerisms are just a part of the creepiness.
Makeup artists turned her into a shiver-inducing
dead ringer of the notorious murderer.
Pepper
American Horror Story: Asylum featured plenty
of unique characters, but none stood out more
than the diminutive Pepper.
A lot of makeup went into overhauling Naomi
Grossman's appearance for the role: It took
two people nearly three hours to apply the
prosthetic details, fake teeth, contact lenses,
and makeup each day.
Grossman even shaved most of her head for
the role.
Liz Taylor
Denis O'Hare's transformation into a transgender
woman for American Horror Story's fifth season
was thorough — and not just on the outside.
Aside from the makeup and outfits, O'Hare
gave a nuanced performance that showed the
emotional impact transitioning can have.
Liz Taylor was the heart and soul of the Hotel
Cortez, and she was simply fabulous.
"I'm sorry Lady, this is a notel motel."
Penny
If you didn't already know Grace Gummer is
Meryl Streep's daughter, you would have had
a tough time seeing the resemblance in American
Horror Story: Freak Show.
To achieve her look as "Lizard Girl," Gummer
endured daily application of an elaborate
puzzle of prosthetic tattoos that covered
her entire head and neck.
Although her forked tongue was added in post-production,
she did sometimes have to wear a silicon applique
as well.
Infantata
Frankenstein had nothing on Infantata.
The late Ben Woolf played the miniature monstrosity
in season 1's Murder House, and the character
was stunning as the reanimated remnants of
the murdered Montgomery child who's also ravenous
for blood.
To capture the unsettling look, Woolf had
to submit to one heck of a makeup routine.
Twisty the Clown
It took a hefty amount of special effects
talent to bring Twisty the Clown to life for
American Horror Story: Freak Show.
In case you've somehow managed to erase the
image of his origins from your nightmares,
Twisty shot off his jaw with a shotgun, leaving
him horribly disfigured beneath his mask.
No amount of makeup could make actor John
Carroll Lynch really look that way, though.
So crew members would paint his face green
and cover it with motion capture sensors for
the chilling CGI effects.
Tate Langdon
Actor Evan Peters' character in Murder House
didn't usually look all that different from
Evan Peters in real life.
But when Tate applied skull makeup before
embarking on his horrific killing spree, it
was thoroughly terrifying and became an instant
favorite for cinch Halloween costuming.
Hypodermic Sally
Sarah Paulson was certainly no newcomer to
the American Horror Story franchise when she
suited up as a drug-addled ghost to haunt
the Hotel Cortez.
Although she also played those memorable conjoined
twins Bette and Dot in Freak Show, she's almost
more unrecognizable as Hypodermic Sally with
her frazzled hair and ghoulish makeup,
Myrtle Snow
Frances Conroy's memorable turn as Myrtle
Snow was an obvious tribute to fashionista
Grace Coddington in Coven and was a brutally
stoic — but honest — witch who didn't
even flinch when burned at the stake.
Those who remembered Conroy best for her prior
TV work as Ruth on Six Feet Under probably
wouldn't even recognize her beneath all that
hair and flair.
Edward Mordrake
Weird facial hair is nothing new for actor
Wes Bentley: he'd already done it in 2012's
The Hunger Games before he joined the crazy
crew of American Horror Story: Freak Show.
But it wasn't just his next-level facial hair
that made his take on Edward Mordrake so memorable.
The 19th Century Brit character also sported
an extra face on the back of his head.
Thanks for watching!
For more spooky videos, our friends at Grunge recently published a video about the scariest clowns caught on
camera. Click the video here or the link in our description to watch it now.
If you like Looper, you’ll love Grunge - The same team makes videos for both channels!